devil épargnés jusqu'ici comme celle ci
dans l'est de l'ukraine et suit
désormais le feu de moscou une usine de
chaussures une maternité ciblées en
cette 16e journée d'invasion
une autre journée à tenter de survivre à
sentir que le pire reste à venir
kiev la capitale est toujours plus
menacés
la possibilité que des combattants du
proche-orient rejoindre volontairement
des troupes russes tel qu'évoqué par le
président vladimir poutine et qui est
président ukrainien et vine l'ennemi
embauche désormais des assassins de
syrie pour nous détruire comme ils l'ont
fait la
baleine ce qui demande en vain une zone
d'exclusion aérienne pour bloquer les
avions russes mais l'occident y voient
un risque de conflit ouvert avec moscou
et même si l'europe lui promet de
poursuivre son aide notamment en
doublant le financement pour l'achat
d'armes à un milliard d'euros et de
continuer à faire preuve de solidarité
comme l'assurent la présidente de la
commission européenne ne pénètrent en
disant que les ukrainiens font déjà
partie de la famille pour la façon dont
ils défendent si courageusement les
valeurs européennes
pas question d'adhérer rapidement à
lugnorre pouvons-nous avoir une
procédure accélérée ou exceptionnelle
avec un pays en guerre sont regardés
aucun critère la réponse est non le
conflit en ukraine force l'europe à
penser à sa sécurité à sa souveraineté à
s'affranchir par exemple de sa
dépendance aux énergies russe elle
espère y arriver d'ici 2027 il nous
faudra dans les prochains mois
révolus et très profondément ce qu'est
notre europe
je crois pouvoir vous dire que la
géopolitique et le retour de la guerre
et du tragique en europe le retour des
révisionnisme historique
les volonté de puissance et d'hégémonie
nous impose de réfléchir à comment nous
voulons organiser
une rampe large en attendant l'occident
recourent encore plus aux sanctions pour
écraser l'économie russe dans l'espoir
de tarifs l'argent de la guerre
fini les importations de vodka et de
diamants aux états unis annonce le
président joe biden finie la relation
commerciale privilégiée avec les alliés
qui évitait à moscou des tarifs
douaniers punitifs
à notre gauche l'agresseur dit il doit
payer et bien que les russes n'ont
encore rien vu si jamais il devait
utiliser des armes chimiques en ukraine
ces libéraux radio canada ben ali